Alright, so we've identified what information this graphic is
communicating. But, you could probably imagine a really bad
graphic that had all the same information. You might
look at it and have no idea what's going on.
Or, it might not tell the story as effectively.
What makes this graphic so effective? Can we quantify
effective information visualization down to a few important ingredients?
I'd like to hear your thoughts again. In your perspective,
what are the ingredients to good information visualization? This
is a free-form question, so there's no right or
wrong answer. Type your answer in this text box.
I'll share my thoughts with you in the next video.